[Musique]
je voudrais aider mais je peux
vouser c'est pas commode d'être à la
mode quand on est bonne du curé c'est
pas facile d'avoir le style quand on est
une fille comme i entre la cure et les
figures des grenouilles de
bnitier la vie est dure quand on aime
rigoler
mais quand le diable qute à mon diable
me tire par les pieds ça me gratouille
ça me chatouille ça me donne des idées
derrière l'église je des bêtises je peux
point m'en empêcher Dieu me pardonne je
suis la bonne du
curé mais qu'est-ce que c'est que cette
bonne femme qui chante mon respéirtoire
mais enfin Madame vous ex je ne suis pas
celle que vous croyez Ben et ben quoi
qu'il en soit retournez donc au
presbyère Ilic presto qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire oh mais c'est qu'elle est
mauvaise celle-là et puis en plus il
paraît il paraît qu'elle chante en
chinois
maintenant